le coût des matières premières
s'envolent les prix de l'énergie flambe
l'inflation grève les budgets des
ménages une équation délétère pour les
petits commerçants même les plus
populaires ou essentiels d'entre eux
sont en souffrance à Rochecorbon la
facture d'électricité d'un boulanger
passe de 900 à plus de 5000 euros par
mois pour suivre ou arrêter son activité
les gérances se posent la question
fausses
madame
dans cette boulangerie de Rochecorbon
Yannick et Shirley Troude subissent de
plein fouet l'inflation le couple vient
de recevoir un avenant sur son contrat
d'électricité multipliant par 6 la
facture elle passe de 900 à 5400 euros
mensuels à cela s'ajoute la hausse du
prix des matières premières 60% de plus
pour le sucre 20% pour la farine 100%
pour le beurre une hausse décharge qui
se répercute sur les prix de leurs
produits y compris sur la baguette
tradition là sur les trois derniers mois
on va dire et elle est passée de indice
à un vin et c'est pas suffisant voilà
c'est pas suffisant pour couvrir en fait
tout ce qu'il y a à payer vous imaginez
le nombre de baguettes qu'il faut vendre
pour atteindre 5400 euros pour
bénéficier du bouclier tarifaire qui
limite à 15 % la hausse de la facture
d'électricité les très petites
entreprises doivent être équipées d'un
compteur électrique d'une puissance
inférieure à 36 kg volts ampères or
celui de notre boulangerie artisanale
atteint les 54 kilos volts ampères
indispensables pour faire fonctionner
son four moi je me demande pourquoi nous
entreprises on n'aurait pas le droit un
bouclier tarifaire pourquoi nous on peut
supporter plus qu'un particulier
une augmentation de x 6 x 10 pour
certains
mais on est Paris 15% c'est c'est ça
peut rester absorbable mais moi
aujourd'hui cette augmentation là elle
représente le salaire et les charges de
mon boulanger est celui de ma vendeuse
or depuis la crise covid leur activité a
ralenti et leur trésorerie à fondu ça va
être très compliqué bah pour payer nos
salariés pour payer nos traites pour
payer nos crédits et on sait pas où on
valait bientôt quoi c'est quoi le risque
pour la boulangerie c'est de fermer tout
simplement selon la Fédération des
boulangers d'undre-et-loire il ne s'agit
pas de la seule boulangerie dans cette
situation les conséquences pourraient
être visibles dès janvier ou février